العد التنازلي للتواجد العسكري الفرنسي في
النيجر قد بدا وزاره القوات المسلحه
الفرنسيه كشفت عن موعد الانسحاب
انسحاب القوات الفرنسيه من النيجر سيبدا
هذا الاسبوع وسيكتمل في نهايه العام
هيئه الاركان الفرنسيه اشارت ايضا الى ان
عمليه انسحاب القوات الفرنسيه ستتم بشكل
نظامي وامن وبالتنسيق مع النيجر القرار
الفرنسي ياتي بعد ازمه استمرت لاكثر من
شهرين مع المجلس العسكري الحاكم في النيجر
الذي اطاح بالرئيس محمد بزومة عقب انقلاب
السادس والعشرين من تموز يوليو الماضي
وكان الرئيس الفرنسي ايماني قد اعلن في
الرابع والعشرين من ايلول سبتمبر الماضي
انهاء التعاون العسكري مع النيجر
والانسحاب التدريجي للجنود الفرنسيين قبل
ثلاثه ايام من مغادره السفير الفرنسي
للنيجر مطلب كان ملحن من قبل الانقلابيين
ومؤيديين مجلس العسكري الذين تظاهروا
سابقا امام القاعده الفرنسيه في العثمانيه
مطالبين برحيل القوات الفرنسيه من بلادهم
والغاء الاتفاقيات العسكريه مع فرنسا